what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time
while walsh is trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get
our lunch money right bang bang
we're back we are back well that's
pretty good we are back
in action we're sorry we missed two days
we missed two days
we know we know we know but we're here
we're in uniform we are ready to rock
and roll don't forget that lunch money
is now sponsored by
blockfy blockfi has three products buy
and sell crypto on their crypto exchange
deposit crypto and earn up to eight
point six percent epy in an interest
bearing account
or you can deposit crypto and take out a
us dollar loan to get your crypto
collateral
go get an account at blockfy.com i'm an
investor i'm a happy user
you will be too go get an account let's
go what's up with the news
well first of all sorry guys but we're
back i did not anticipate that there
would be so many activities on thursday
and friday morning
that by the time we were ready for lunch
money was like 4 p.m and i was like well
but we're back sorry it's gonna be
bigger and better than ever
starting with mass mutual buys a hundred
million in
bitcoin and bets on institutional
adoption with a five
million dollar nydig stake i don't know
what nydig
is but it is significant news that mass
mutual
got into the bitcoin game with a hundred
million dollar investment what do you
think
this is really really small it's like
.04
for mass mutual yeah 0.04 of their
assets
it's very very very small but
the good news is that they're in the
game 100 million dollars nice round
number my guess is they're just dipping
their toe in the water and then they're
gonna
go and accelerate from here let's
see what's up i can't wait it's gonna be
fun
uh i tend to think that uh this will
be just the beginning for insurance
companies they're usually very
conservative obviously them
stepping into bitcoin means that maybe
they are opening up the idea
ny digg uh also said in the
uh in their press release that they have
actually on board a number of insurance
companies so
bang bang let's get it guys the reason
my hair looks so funny
is because i had it up in a bun and now
it's like poofy okay
uh just in case people were wondering
fidelity investment ceo abby johnson
says the mutual funds
the mutual fund giants custody business
around bitcoin
has been incredibly successful and has a
tremendous
pipeline so johnson noted that
developments in the sector are moving so
rapidly it's hard to keep track of
all of them it's important to remember
that abby johnson was one of the
first believers from the institutional
side in bitcoin correct
absolutely uh abby johnson ended up
being
um i think in 2016 or 15.
they created a bitcoin mining facility
they
really really understood this they
started to work on it
and now what you end up finding is that
abby johnson has
not only uh kind of said okay look this
is valuable they think this is going to
be one of the most valuable things that
they do
and so what they are in the process of
is building an entire digital assets
business it's literally called fidelity
digital assets
um and they continue to onboard users uh
they continue to onboard institutions
and i think a lot of people trust the
fidelity brand and so when they see that
they're involved that they provide
custody services
that is a really big advantage and so
you know those who are early and believe
before everyone else
usually get rewarded that's what we're
watching right here awesome
tesla will shut down production lines
for its high-end but
older electric vehicles the model s
sedan and model x suv for 18 days
beginning on december 24th
employees working on the lines were told
they were being given a full week of pay
for the first time off but were
encouraged to seek
shifts working for or even volunteering
in
other parts of the business for the
remaining unpaid
days i wonder why yeah look
to me this is uh tesla's to keep
creating as many vehicles as they
possibly can but i think there's
a thought that there's not enough demand
for the older
uh models so
yeah i mean yes for sure but i also
think that it's not like tesla's saying
hey we're not going to produce any cars
right it's just a certain type of car
um and so sure the demand for older cars
is going to go down if you keep
launching cool new cars right
cool new car should we get a tesla
that wasn't a no all right next
roblox the gaming company that has been
preparing to go public
has decided to delay its ipo until next
year
and assign the enthusiastic market for
ipos by doordash and airbnb this past
week has made it difficult to price
shares accurately
so i read another analysis that
basically roblox looked at what happened
with airbnb and door
in doordash which their share price
uh went up than what they had expected
so they didn't want employees to feel
like you know they were being
shortchanged
if they went public and suddenly they
left money on the table
what do you think i mean
it's awesome to see a ceo who is trying
to think holistically and understand
that there are shareholders across the
cap table
uh that they need to take care of uh and
it is really
interesting that in a frothy market
somebody says wait a second this is too
frothy
let me take a step back let's let kind
of the dust settle and then we'll go
into the public markets
um they've got a great business i mean
it's a fantastic uh
business and so i think that uh what
you're watching
happen here is uh maybe some maturity
um and he also is operating with more
information so doordash and airbnb
obviously didn't have the information
that he has
um and so you know i think that more
people should kind of give this guy
kudos
david basuki
and basically say look we need more
people to be rational to to kind of do
the right thing
interesting like don't you think that he
would want to go public in a frothy
market
well there's a couple of different
considerations so if
insiders are selling their stock to
new investors in the ipo process and
then there's a massive
boom so i'll say then this shares you
know double on day one
that means it was priced incorrectly if
it was priced incorrectly that means
they sold for 50
less than what other people are buying
it for a day later right that's not good
um but they may just issue new stock
like there's all these kind of nuances
so i don't want to get super deep into
the
the weeds um but i do think that uh
this is just like a very um smart mature
rational uh thing for them to do
uh and frankly i'm pumped that they're
doing it because hopefully other people
follow suit if uh if it makes sense for
them
cool also note that today i'm wearing a
black t-shirt and you are not
i'm wearing a black shirt that's gray no
it's black it just is worn out go ahead
bite dance the company behind social
media sensation tick tock
is in talks to raise another two billion
dollars before the initial public
offering of a large chunk of its
international business
on the hong kong stock exchange wow
i love it why i mean
they're exploding in growth and revenue
is exploding as well
and so they feel like not only through
tick tock but their other assets
uh they're an incredibly valuable
attractive business so remember when
trump was going to shut down tick tock
what happened i don't know but they
generate 17 billion dollars in revenue
not shut yet 17 billion in revenue this
is a massive
business and they've got a bunch of
different product tick tock is one of
them uh
and so when you have a big business like
that like at some point you so
decide that you're gonna go and you're
going to uh
grow like you're gonna keep raising
capital and fueling the fire i think
business news in tech news is very u.s
centric
but when i went to china uh for a
conference one time
i mean just talking to the investors
there and talking to some of the
the companies and the ceos based in
china by
dance the it's a parent company of all
these different
products and apps there's one it's
called do do young
i can't pronounce it uh but anyway so
it's a news aggregator
it's so extremely popular in china
and i at the time when i heard i was
like who is who's using this and it's
like
a lot of people so i think a lot of us
underestimate the size of the chinese
business of some of these
like companies like fight dance and over
state tick tock for example because
that's all we know
that's probably fair okay ready what
next
cameo brian
baumgartner the actor who played kevin
on the office will make more than
one million dollars on celebrity booking
site cameo this year that makes him the
platform's top
earner of 2020. that's crazy
wow yeah one million dollars from that
app and he charged 195
a video not like their celebrities like
um
uh what's his name uh
oh my god chandler from friends perry
matthew matthew perry charges a thousand
dollars a video
but this guy charges 195 and i bet he's
making well he is making more
wow it's pretty crazy that uh 195
dollars
a video means that he averaged 14 videos
per day in 2020. i mean that's like what
14 minutes of his time because each
video is one or two minutes each
not even yeah but you still gotta like
prepare you gotta maybe redo a couple
so half hour do you wanna hear a few
other juicy details about cameo
fun facts youtuber david dobrik is the
most requested celebrity that's not on
the platform he's requested
way more than a beyonce or a jlo said
steven gallanis
the ceo of cameo but gallanis thinks
president trump would crush
dobrik if he joined cameo 15 trump
impersonators have collectively done
3.2 million this year in gross
merchandise value
that's crazy wow that's crazy i bet you
i bet you trump supporters
and anti-trump supporters are using the
of course the trump impersonator videos
of course
that's pretty awesome all right what's
next it is lunch money time
ask lunch money ask lm in the comments
pomp uh kyle douglas asks this pomp
would you ever consider running for
president
no why i like my life
i like having a private life and you
know i just hang out with people
just chill it's great just seems like
too much stress
seems like too much um constant
bickering and arguing and
just uh and attacking yeah and it's just
i think we need more coalition building
i think we need more
agreement more centric uh type
viewpoints in the world
um as we look at it right now politics
is very divisive
and i just don't think that that's
something that i want to spend my day
uh allocating my time towards so you
know just not something that i'm
interested in
and to the after like matthew
asks what's keeping bitcoin developers
from introducing some kind of bug
either on accident or deliberate
sabotage that would crash everything
is there some kind of safeguard against
something like that for example does the
entire developer community need to agree
to change the code or can new code
negatively impact the blockchain at all
that's a very good question m to the
atheu
p to the olena hey to that
stop uh no there could be bugs
introduced
um and that's why the development
process is fairly slow and very very
intentional
uh there's a lot of eyes that go on code
before it gets uh
brought in um and uh so you know that is
a potential risk i think it's a low
probability risk
and there's a lot of safeguards and
processes in place
to uh to prevent that from happening so
like other coders check the code
or no yeah i mean there's code reviews
and all that kind of stuff and
uh you know it just is something that
could happen but again very very
unlikely that it occurs
interesting well it hasn't happened in
10 years which is interesting
right go ahead has that happened there
there have been bugs in the code for
sure oh but it hasn't crashed the whole
blockchain
frankie asks hey pomp and paulina
monday's noah galloway interview
was phenomenal by the way ah that's the
interview i did
on my youtube channe change youtube
page go check out uh paulina marinova
pompliano on youtube to find the noah
galloway
interview his question is i manage my
crypto in a retail exchange account but
also have holdings for my older
relatives and parents in the same
account
my concern is that as bitcoin continues
its rise and these numbers become much
larger
i might be targeted by the irs or have
some sort of tax issue
do you have any advice for the scores of
us that hold the crypto assets of family
members
in our personal accounts thanks i'm not
an accountant
you should go talk to an accountant uh i
believe
it's my personal opinion right this is
not a financial advice for accounting
advice
uh i believe that you will be
responsible for the tax
uh if it's under your name in your
account even if it's like yo my buddy
down the street or my brother
gave me some money to buy bitcoin for
them that sits in my account uh the irs
says what's in your account under your
name
uh from what i understand so i think
that uh you probably
should figure out a different way to do
it including just setting up a separate
account for uh for family members having
them
um you know put their names in and their
information so that you can keep
everything separate
but again go talk to them do the
research yeah well just talk to an
accountant like
that's one of those questions that like
can have a pretty serious impact
uh on your tax situation so i definitely
would go and
have that discussion cool thank you guys
that was
awesome and i'm glad to be back
speak p to the only a to the anthony
anthony yes that's it all right guys see
you tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
black lives my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find up to 8.6 interest on
a deposit in an interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risks
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends